what does it mean for you to come here
to London and bring the show that is so
up here in the UK we'd like it to be on
a channel here in the U a but because we
know most people who watch it probably
either watch it probably watch it online
but we love our international fans we're
very happy to be here and it's nice to
actually meet people face to face for a
writer myself how do you guys feel oh
it's so exciting it's my first time in
London it's been amazing everyone's been
so kind and it's just really encouraging
to know that we have so much support
here dealing it's your first season on
the show and Arden it's your first full
season how's it been good it's been
really good yeah I mean we dived right
in and it was amazing it's a great show
it's well it's sort of your second oh
yeah my second season yeah she's done 20
you've done 24 episodes now well 22 just
about did you come on 3b yes over here
yeah review is nuts it came in and we
just went we just went for it but it was
awesome it was so much fun and we just
yeah I get down and dirty it's good
Dylan's been a great addition to the
show he's uh he's actually our first
actual teenager so we are all teenagers
Jeff don't yeah well actually Dylan and
taya word 19 when they first started the
show so but everybody's getting up there
in age now what are you looking forward
to going forward would you like your
character to go for the next season
everyone's very excited about you have
some ideas comic-con this year me where
would you like to see a character ah
probably just you know growing up a
little bit kind of joining the wolf pack
a little bit more and helping out and
kind of being more confident in himself
as a as a werewolf you both want to get
in on more of the action right yeah
we've I think about that I just want to
be stronger and understand my powers
better and just really be sure of who we
are and especially for Keira I think
there's so much still to discover about
her gifts and her talents and all of its
really new and it's different from the
world so I think that's really fun and
hopefully like Scott and Carol really
make that power couple thing happen yeah
okay we like seeing uh Scott and Keira
together I like the action too
I wanna I wanna see Kira with her sword
more often
I like the nunchucks - I want to bring
those other than nunchucks for fun I was
like that was fun we only love the
glowstick nunchucks yeah yeah that was
very cool um my question is and both of
you guys came into this so I have to see
season 3 be one year and then season for
yourself
was there any difficulty like meshing
with the guys I were already there or
was a very easy to integrate into the
shell I thought it was pretty easy
because they're really welcoming and it
was nice because the crew and the actors
everybody was really comfortable with
each other and they kind of know how to
work and so you sort of just jump in
there and kind of just go with it
you know and it's nice when something's
already established so you just follow
the routine in a sense I mean of course
it's like being the new kid but for my
character I thought it was easy cuz I
was playing the new kid so it's kind of
very natural in the way that it worked
with the acting and the normal real life
stuff I guess I know yeah
yes actually she said it right it being
well I stuff that on but you know being
a new kid kind of onset in on screen
kind of works together and then also I
think it's just you start at such a fast
pace with the with everyone that's
working you know I jumped right in the
first day of filming I was hanging off a
building um it's just you just get
really used to it you you know learn
people's names on the way and yeah you
know you just keep on moving we're we're
very lucky we have our cast is
unbelievably nice Dylan Tyler Tyler
Holland they're all so welcoming I
remember actually when the twins Max and
Charley first came on we were all
nervous because these were our first
real new cast members and we were we
were hoping that they would be accepted
and welcomed and they were welcomed
immediately everyone treats each other
like kind of a big family
I have fights sometimes like a family
but uh luckily they have some parents in
producers around them but um we have one
of the best cast ever I think and I know
every show says that but we do I think
we do yeah
uh the shares I'm very physically
demanding I mean you have to do quite a
bit of martial arts and yet using
nunchucks how much training do you guys
have to go through she knew enough she's
great thanks Jeff you got to talk about
your stunt double though cuz ya know I
have an amazing stunt double and our
coordinators are really great and I'm
really I think all of us are really
lucky that our stunt doubles really take
the time to teach us as much as they can
in sometimes the five minutes that we
have before the scene or sometimes we
get lucky we'll get a full hour I think
there was maybe one fight sequence we
got almost a full day to learn something
that's amazing that never really happens
but luckily we learn as much as we can
on the spot and then they kind of fill
in the blanks for us and I think for me
I feel like a little bit lucky because I
come from a background where I learned
martial arts growing up and so there are
some things that I already knew how to
do and of course I'm learning a lot on
the way also not you you had a great
sound able to yeah but you only had one
or two scenes though yeah I just wanted
a few fight scenes but um I said I mean
I stay in shape for the character we're
gonna get you back and we're gonna get
we're gonna add him in the action next
season I'm more fighting for Dylan not
more running and jumping but Tyler Posey
has Dave Elson who's been with us for
quite a while and Dave played uh he was
a stunt double for spider-man in the
first movie I think he did the second
movie - but he's phenomenal and Dave
always goes through the motions with
Tyler Posey and Posey loves the action
he loves getting into the fights he
learns a lot of it and he learns it
really fast
so yeah Dave I do remember we did a with
the Berserker scene that whole last
uh-huh last segment that choking part it
was Dave in the show yeah he was acting
it all out - and he was doing really
good yeah he's are really in - yeah
you wouldn't even know Allegiant took my
stunt double agent took a crazy hit when
we're doing the Berserker the chain
fight she takes his hit work goes
straight into the like what was it like
a gated was it the elevator door yeah
yeah I think so but they had her on this
like a fire yeah on a pull wire but I
mean they pulled it so hard the actual
like gate pretty much collapse like
monitor her and I mean she got she was
wearing something on her back that right
yeah but
she still got like tore up cuz my
wardrobe all it was was like tights and
a shirt a jacket it was so thin that she
like no protection and I was like oh my
god you poor thing but she was such a
trooper and she was like I loved it it
was great she's like show me the tape
because I filmed it on this I love their
battle scars yeah you're like proud of
them remember one tell Matt you were you
doing a day on the finale whenever we
were doing this stuff that last final
battle and like I tripped and fell in
the scene and the yeah you guys actually
used that one I don't think I saw that
one no I I was walking back and I trip
which is part of the scene but the stunt
I was supposed to do it but I just
tripped and fell and both my feet were
like this and I hit my head and that was
the scene we use that that one that they
used excellent would been sad not to
today yeah no this yeah you took the
head it was a real fall like both my
feet right here it wasn't like a like I
rolled or something I just fell yeah
cura Falls a lot too you didn't see that
cut see all right let's keep on I mean
I'm curious obviously fans have their
favorite characters apart Miran and
obviously in general is our particular
character you especially identify with
or just really enjoy watching or working
one other thing you're wrong well so my
favorite character definitely from the
beginning was I always loved Stiles just
cuz he's just like the comedic relief
and he's so fun and cute but then coming
on to season four I really liked Shelley
because she's almost just like Stiles in
a sense but like Dreyer
I love the comedy in it and the humor
and so I love Malia's character a lot
and I was actually asking Jeff if Malia
and kira kira could have more
interactions and more comedy because I
think I'm Tate to see that yeah it's
nice to see that with the girls for a
change because we've always had like
Scott and Stiles but we're all which I
love Scott always getting the note more
romance more romance yeah but I feel
like it's I feel like I shouldn't say
Scott's my favorite although like of
course Karen Scott are making how about
you uh I was like stilinski chef
stilinski I love the shirt it's
hilarious he just like especially in
those first few seasons but he didn't
know what was going on and they finally
found out just that kind of like that
kind of once he like hears the stories
of what's happening for real he just
goes
he doesn't even know how to handle it
too it's just I am I love writing for
Ian Bohen he's such a sassy sarcastic
villain and often times the writer
really chooses the villain to get their
own sort of feelings out you know he's
he's sort of my voice like that inner
deepest darkest voice and we love those
characters all those snarky one like I
wouldn't say he's my favorite character
I can never make a favorite guys Teen
Wolf the TV series came about after the
movie Teen Wolf with Michael J Fox I was
just wondering if you'd had any thoughts
about making a Teen Wolf movie yourself
and what that might be
well Tyler Posey and I always talked
about what we'll do for the movie I
personally like to do a movie just to
have the time in preparation I could
spend months writing one script instead
of three days writing one script and we
would have prepped for fight scenes and
we'd have a bigger budget it would be
really fun if the fifth season is
potentially the last season of Teen Wolf
then I'd love for there to be a movie
afterwards what do you guys think go for
a movie dude that'd be awesome and
you're up from the movie pay yeah we
work hard I think a movie would be nice
that's between you and your your agents
in the network and then that work yes
what would you guys like seeing your
characters in the Shema food lots of
action and drama and heartbreak yeah I
think also just depends on what happens
is next season too
because um yeah I have no idea mean if
you survive if I know that's a good boy
thank you if we're bad they kill us so
yeah that's the great thing about doing
a genre show if the actors are bad you
can just kill them is that what happened
to Scott's first lemon dress no no no we
actually I miss crystal and I miss
crystal Tom we text here and there and
um that was actually a I was sort of
shocking it shocked me actually I can't
watch it anymore
get to her it's it's first of all it's
kind of violent so it's sort of stunning
for me to see one of my own characters
be impaled on screen I remember seeing
the daily and I was like wow did we
really do that but I thought it was good
for the show of in in the end of things
uh it shook things up the show needed a
kind of reboot I think especially after
a certain number of episodes we've done
60 episodes now we've got 20 more it's
kind of it's shocking to me that it's
surprising I should say that Teen Wolf
has gone 80 episodes and now when I am I
talked to fans they come up to me some
fans come to me and says how did you
come up with the idea for Teen Wolf I'm
like well I didn't it was a movie do you
remember the Michael J Fox movie and
people look at me and say no they're too
young I guess um so yeah uh you brought
up Michael J Fox then um has there been
any discussion about having him come on
for a cameo low we get a lot of this
question a lot um I would love that
uh I know he knows of the show but I
don't he's seen it has he said anything
has he contacted the show at all no we
should get in touch with him shouldn't
wait but there was a certain point with
the network where they wanted to
completely distance themselves from the
original movie but um is that because
you're so vastly different and yeah yeah
I think we wanted to get away from it I
mean in in Hollywood these days it's all
about branding and very little is made
without a previous brand the spec market
for movies has been completely destroyed
they're only interested in making toys
and and games into movies or books that
are known properties so for me when they
asked me to do Teen Wolf I said okay
it's a brand it has that much more
potential to be made as a TV series but
it was really just a jumping-off point
we very very much have we there's very
little left of the movie in this TV
series which is fine because who knew
that 60 episodes would be made out of
Michael J Fox basketball comedy starring
awareness what can you guys see the
season five man how many oh you can
think okay um uh I can tease very little
of season five other than well we've
only done about a week or so in the
writers room just brainstorming ideas
we're really happy to have time now to
we've got our longest break in two and a
half years we it was actually sort of
kind of a marathon the last two years
because if we put in we aired in 14
months 36 episodes which is very hard to
do for a show like ours so we now have a
good bit of preparation so we're really
think keeping things open but we we can
say that it's senior year it's going to
be 20 episodes instead of the twelve
episodes story arc we're going to do a
full story arc through the 20 episodes
with probably a big cliffhanger in the
middle if there's a season 6 that would
be great but that's sort of up in the
air we'll see it's not my decision it's
networks but uh it'd be amazing you have
a lot of monsters in the show obviously
um but there's there's such a lexicon of
monsters I mean you actually have a
lexicon of monsters we have a bestiary
yeah be scary
um not asking you for like a spoiler
anything but are there any monsters that
you would like to show up in the show at
some point that you can tell us about um
well uh we're working on something new
we do have some new villains for this
season but we've we've had a lot of
we've had a lot of fun playing with old
mythologies
um if I could do if I could actually
have any kind of monster in the show I
would want to bring back the the Beast
the really big beast of kind of werewolf
from season 1 actually it's just so
expensive to do that level of
gie you'd be amazed at what our CGI
budget is I I think we get the most bang
for the buck out of the CGI this this
season and last because we've learned
how to do it we learn new things every
season we've learned how to do it in a
way that it looks like we have a much
bigger budget than we do but I'd love to
see a huge hulking werewolf though the
big beast from season one done with a
hundred million dollar budget not likely
that we're going to see that it any time
for the movie the movie yes everything
if you got to spend any more screen time
with other characters in upcoming season
five who do not share more screen time
with what do you want to play against
hmm
I don't know I like everyone I like I
think it'd be nice just to work more
with everybody like more balanced yeah
cuz you know I thought it'd be cute if
we did some double dating with we're
working on that actually yeah and then
triple dating if I think it liam a girl
for somebody um I think that would be
cute I like I like seeing you and Scott
and fight scenes are you and Posey and
fight scenes I I kind of missed that
that from well I we had fun pairing you
and you guys together I thought we did
see well together - that was fun yeah I
think I just I liked seeing you guys
with with Dylan with Stiles oh yes funny
yeah I loved in when he's like kids yeah
when we run out I particularly like um
Tyler and Dylan with you you know
because he's very much like we really
wanted to give Tyler and Dylan sort of a
little brother and he fit right into
that I like the comedy scenes where they
like tackle you yes do you like playing
against um I like playing against that
that that a trio right there but I think
in the next season I want to play more
with my um my like parents and stuff
yeah
like you so my parents and my vehicle
bombings or anything like that
we'll see nobody on the show has
siblings we're all to expense ones only
Chaya that's right except for us a halos
the hills yes what wins yeah
mr. twins Oh said why we're hopefully
yeah maybe they'll come back for ya
we'll say a little bit here and there
well one of them whatever I write yeah
no that was see that was sad too
I know but that was really unexpected so
I guess I'm sure it was exciting
hopefully worth dramatically and I had a
specific question more for you Arden I
know Leah works mostly in Hollywood and
and us TV series except and I wanted you
to tell me more compared in olliewood
films compared to series sometimes Asian
actors are typecasting how do you see
learning to talk about this
Arden loves talking about this one
actually I don't want to answer for you
it's horrible
the typecasting that happens in this
[ __ ] it's yeah how much flexibility in
Seymour television we're often we say
that Asian actors like um the lead
actress in grade Grey's Anatomy
korean-american was also even a full
role a lead role and while in olliewood
films maybe this it's more limited but
also in terms of skill development and
character development that doesn't allow
as much as flexibility in terms of
binary factors
well it's very loaded question and
answer and shortly in the way how many
times are you asked to do an accent a
lot and how many times we know not to
play your nationality all the time I
think the main difference is so you're
asking the difference between films and
series I think in films it's harder
because you're trying to reach that
mass-market and they just want you know
what's going to be the most relatable
and you know to develop a character a
lot of times with films they say it's
too hard to make someone a minority and
then explain the situation on their
parents and siblings and all sorts of
things like that like on a show like
Teen Wolf I'm really lucky that the
writers and directors and producers are
all open to kind of creating a family
that makes sense
my mother is Japanese my father's Korean
making me therefore half and you know
they kind of built a story through
season 3b that made sense and I don't
know it also gave us a way to show that
um that the the mother's name can be
taken by the man all right right
Japanese culture because of the house
and it's unfortunate that that so much
of TV and film is they only look for the
Asian actor actress to play the massage
girl or the kung-fu fighter Sandra Oh
was amazing was amazing on Grey's
Anatomy
and that's really due to Shonda Rhimes
though right who's the best at it I mean
she is the most diverse shows on
television but finding Arden was hard we
we saw quite a few girls and she's
amazing
she's perfect oh you're so sweet I think
a lot of it also comes down to like Jeff
said content and having content
available that fit someone who happens
to be Asian American or Asian or doesn't
need to be you know I think a lot of
times the things I like about Kira is
that Kira could have been anything she
could have been any sort of I think
ethnicity I know a lot of it follows
that Asian mythology but didn't have to
know I think it only followed that just
because I happen to be Asian and you
know I think in the future in the next
few years it'll get better I mean I
heard now there's a new action hero
Cindy moon silk I'm sure you heard of
and I think she would be Korean I hope I
get that you heard about that no I
haven't Oh take a female version of
spider-man says she's bit by the same
spider that spider-man's whipped by and
her name is Cindy moon Wow it's a new
character that got released so that's
cool
I know super cool and I'm like totally
into that it's like oh my god it's the
coolest thing I've ever heard I hope
they make it a movie like tomorrow well
hope you get the part I hope I get an
audition
you